la parole autochtone ici c'est melissa
maulin depuis sept semaines
éditions dans les bois nous avons comme
beaucoup de gens dû adapter nos formules
et nos manières de faire en lien avec la
crise sanitaire qui nous touchent
présentement
d'ailleurs au cours des prochaines
semaines nous allons moins répondre aux
questions qui sont tournés vers les
intérêts de nos auditeurs mais plus
tourné vers les questions qui nous
concerne en tant que première nation sur
la crise que 20,19 d'ailleurs c'est
c'est quand même un aspect qu'on voit
pas aussi souvent que les autres c'est à
dire le point de vue des premières
nations
cependant nous avons quand même pu
entendre beaucoup des choses qui sont
préparés des choses qui se sont
instaurées dans les communautés
autochtones
je pense particulièrement à ma
communauté présentement qui a fermé
l'accès à la communauté et permet
uniquement ceux qui habitent de rentrer
et de sortir en encourageant
définitivement les gens à aller
uniquement faire leurs achats
nécessaires et se tenir
quand même distants les uns des autres
ce qui est très difficile dans une
communauté qui est très proche
socialement de est aussi très proche au
niveau des habitations
on s'entend qu'on est encore dans des
communautés où il ya des financements
par rapport aux habitations aux maisons
alors il faut de plus en plus de
logements pour les familles qui sont
quand même assez grandissant cependant
ces politiques n'ont mis en place par
les communautés et aussi par le
gouvernement du québec permet de créer
une distance physique plutôt qu'une
distance sociale une amie sur les médias
sociaux qui m'a fait remarquer ce point
là c'est de ça qu'on devrait parler plus
parce qu'on parle d'une distanciation
sociale surtout pour les premiers les
premiers peuples que ce soit les
premières nations au québec où les inuit
dans le nom c indique quelque chose qui
historiquement est très négatif quand
même parce qu'une distance sociale veut
souvent dire une répartition sociale qui
est inégal donc on va passer beaucoup à
la crise du h1n1
par exemple en 2009 où on à l'histoire
de certaines communautés qui ont demandé
de l'aide au gouvernement est plutôt que
d'envoyer des médecins ou des
médicaments ils ont envoyé des sacs pour
les cadors
donc vous pouvez imaginer que une
sensation social ce n'est pas
souhaitable
en ce moment on peut en voir la
distanciation sociale si on regarde les
politiques aux etats-unis où si on
regarde mais au brésil et sa salle a des
conséquences désastreuses et même
mortelles pour beaucoup de communautés
parce que certaines des communautés
riche elle s'en sort très bien en
pouvant se payer de l'isolément physique
et les communautés plus pauvres je pense
particulièrement aux favelas au brésil
qui elles vont subir le gros coup de
la vague 19 donc qu'on pense distance
physique on peuvent aussi voir comment
que ça a été bénéfique pour les
communautés autochtones à une époque en
1919 quand il ya eu justement la grippe
espagnole est bien certaine communauté
qui n'était pas encore forcer sur les
réserves je pense à certaines
communautés de la côte nord les inouk y
accéder encore au territoire librement
ont pu se garder physiquement distant et
donc les populations ont beaucoup moins
subi le contrecoup de la grippe
espagnole que certaines des communautés
qui l avait été sédentarisés notre force
et on eu beaucoup de dessins au sein de
leur communauté et à cette époque là la
distanciation sociale ajoutée à la
distanciation physique ce à dire que les
blancs à l'époque ne se mélangeaient pas
avec les indiens a fait que ces
communautés là s'en sont mieux sortis et
malheureusement la distanciation sociale
à cette époque là aussi fait que ceux
qui étaient dans les réserves ont pas eu
accès aux mêmes qui a été de soins ont
pas eu le même support du gouvernement
donc en espérant que on continue dans
ses belles 22 de rapprochement social de
jeu tiré de renforcement communautaire
convoi au québec on pourrait s'en sortir
avec beaucoup moins de décès que
certains des pays voisins qui vont eux à
subir les contrecoups de leurs décisions
beaucoup trop timide par rapport à
protéger leurs populations
alors vous imaginez c'est très
inquiétant aussi pour nos frères et nos
soeurs qui sont aux états unis qui
vivent dans des réserves dans les
communautés du sud
donc ça va être de garder la tournée
vers ses communautés leur offrir une
voie quand ils en ont besoin et être à
l'écouté de leurs besoins parce que l'on
sait que la fermeture des vols d'avions
par exemple cause des problèmes
d'approvisionnement dans le gréement et
la paire de sécurité alimentaire donc
cette grande chaîne très fragile
qui vient avec justement l'économie
nord-américaine et capitaliste va
s'effondrer donc on va vraiment
nécessairement besoin de solidarité
communautaire et ça je pense que c'est
ce qu'on doit retenir plus que la
distance c'est une qui a malheureusement
causé beaucoup de problèmes au sein des
communautés autochtones
alors j'espère qu'on va pouvoir entendre
de vos questions de vos préoccupations
justement en lien que 19 ans née avec la
crise en lien avec justement la distance
physique et la distance sociale qui
pourrait en émane et n'hésitez pas à
nous envoyer ces questions là j'espère
que vous allez vous garder en santé et
distants les uns par les autres mes
proches dans votre coeur souhaite une
belle semaine